hey guys Pete here this is going to be
my top moments video for Twin Peaks the
return episode 10 if you haven't watched
episode 10 you'll want to stop watching
this video because it will spoil it I
guess since episode was slightly subdued
to what the we've seen in the last few
parts but I still really enjoyed it we
started off at Miriam's trailer kind of
had a feeling that Miriam wasn't going
to have the best life expectancy after
we saw that she saw a richard horn kill
that child in the hit and run and sure
enough richard stayed true to his
character and was a complete bastard
after he found out miriam has done a
letter to the sheriff he stormed inside
her house I guess it's notable to
mention that she was still alive when he
left you could see her breathing on the
floor there but he lit a candle and the
oven was open and turned on and we saw a
large pool of blood there the next big
moment was that he immediately contacted
Chad deputy Chad and told him to
intercept the letter at the cilenti
sheriff's apartment we knew he had some
dealings with Chad but it looks like
they're really in deep together so
that's just a little bit of confirmation
on that the next big scene or a big
moment for me was without a doubt called
Rod jamming on the guitar outside his
trailer Harry Dean Stanton is amazing
and I think that it should be kind of
like there should be a compulsory call
Rod scene like this in every episode
till the end I could watch him do
anything basically I really loved him
but yeah we saw him there he is minding
his own business having a nice little
strum on the guitar and we see that
Becky and Stephen live in the fat trout
and that there is some tension if not
outright violence going on in their
relationship so that would be the next
big moment Becky
is in a situation that may be worse than
what we originally realized then we had
candy and the fly we found out a lot
about the Mitchum brothers this week but
the three girls that follow them around
the show girl
Mandie candy and sandy are still a bit
of a mystery but candy and this episode
took a front stage role and you know the
first big moment with her was the
pursuit of the fly and what I loved
about this scene was as you knew what
was going to happen like it wasn't a
surprise at all whenever she picked up
the remote control that she was going to
end up hitting Rodney Mitchum in the
face with it but it still worked for
some reason and I think the actress who
plays candy Amy Shields did a good job
throughout this episode where it seemed
like they were only going to be
background characters she did a
fantastic portrayal here I don't know
what else to say it was just really good
the next big moment was dougie and Janie
II going to the doctor which turned out
to be absolutely disappointing in a way
that the doctor didn't seem to find
anything with dougie but there was some
funny moments there as they got into the
examination the doctor mentioned that he
had lost weight and we just think for a
second what the original dougie Jones
looked like then we have Kyle MacLachlan
who is obviously in good shape here and
we saw Jamie E sitting there and it's
like she noticed for the first time and
I was cracking out like there's a little
there's a little thin of a smile and her
lips there and it's just it's just funny
so like I said it was kind of a
disappointment because I was hoping that
we would get some insight into what was
going on with their thought process
other than you know they're just like
always acting weird but the Jamie thing
was definitely funny
next big moment was we saw that Ike the
spike being caught was on TV the biggest
laugh I had in this episode and there
were a few for sure but the biggest
laugh I had though was when Jamie was
being interviewed on TV and Dougie coot
kept trying to touch the badge like it's
hilarious I was watching at a cafe and I
laughed out loud
literally and yeah it's it's not a bad
dougie episode really I kind of enjoyed
most of the scenes he was in this time
but we find out that the Mitchum's know
who Ike is and this sets some things
into motion but I guess we'll talk about
that a little bit later
the next big moment was Jaime being in
full lust mode when they get back it was
funny to see the transformation of the
look that she gave in the doctor's
office to where she ended up in when
they were at home Dougy coops in there
eating chocolate cake and doesn't seem
to notice at all but eventually they end
up in bed and again comic Hawking just
sort of nailed this Dougie Cooper thing
here like the arms going up and down and
the big smile on his face
definitely a good little laugh there we
got some dr. Jacoby that was a moment
and we also got a little bit of Nadine
Jacobi's line no wolf for us had me
cracking up he's an angry man we
mentioned that the secret history that
he we found out he lost his license to
practice because of Laura and he seems
to be bitter and on the offensive there
with his YouTube channel or whatever it
is he's doing we also saw that Nadine
has a shop so I guess she eventually got
her noiseless drapes or drape runners I
guess off the ground and there's a
strange scene where we see the curtain
kind of open and closed to showcase one
of those gold shovels from Jacoby but
yeah it's been a while since we've seen
either one of these two so it's good to
see they're there but it was also just a
fleeting thing and didn't really get us
going too much the next big moment was
that we learned Johnny is all right he's
a little worse for the wear but he is
still alive at the very least and we met
his little bear that just says over and
over again
hello Johnny how are you today this was
kind of a bummer because that website
commercials I hate had that was what
they had released I really like they do
every week and so a lot of people got to
thinking and that was going to be
Audrey's first words in the season and
she would show up and obviously it was
this creepy bear that said it instead
but then we even see what might be worse
than what we've seen Richard Horne do
before I mean he killed a child so I
guess it's just all the same but we
see that there's really nothing good
about this character he comes in and
threatens his grandmother he chokes her
somewhat and then he takes all of her
money and jewels and poor Johnny is just
there and it's it's a really
heart-wrenching kind of scene not the
kind that makes you feel good afterwards
that's for sure
so a big moment but Richard horn is very
much irredeemable at this point and we
really didn't find out much more about
him except for that yeah he's a horn and
Silvia is his grandmother we see then
the next moment we see that Tony
Sinclair is involved with mr. Todd and
he's now responsible for the dougie
Jones hit mr. Chaddha and a pretty cool
scene tells him that he'd better go over
and tell the Mitchum brothers that the
reason they lost 30 million on that
insurance claim was directly related to
dougie Jones and the dougie Jones has it
out for him the next big moment was
candy again and her scene in the
security room was fascinating Lee
mysterious the way they had to say her
name several times before she even
responded and then just responded by
saying the same things it was almost
like a dougie mirror in a way but she's
obviously a lot lot more
high-functioning than he is but anyway
she goes out she brings the guy in and
it's just bizarre we do hear one of the
mentioned brothers say that she has
nowhere to go if we fire her so I have a
feeling when I learn more about these
three showgirls as things go on next big
moment was Gordon's drawing and then
whenever he goes over to the door to
answer it he sees Laura Palmer which is
pretty fascinating we haven't seen any
other characters have this sort of
vision so yeah after he opens the door
he sees Laura's image Albert then comes
in to deliver the next big moment
they're monitoring Diane's
communications and they saw the message
that we saw he says at first they
weren't sure if it was important because
you know it came from a tower in
Philadelphia but they looked a little
further and they found out it was
relayed from Mexico and they found out
that she responded they have haste
he is going to take them to the site so
that's a bit of mystery there we'll get
into that more in the recap and review
but yeah that was a big moment without a
doubt not to be outdone Tammie delivers
our next big moment by telling them that
they had image from the early cards at
the glass box experiment was in New York
City and who is in the photos but evil
coupe so yeah that is good to get
something about that part of the story
for sure and we find out evil coupe was
there in the early stages speculate away
about that the final big moment for me
was log ladies return and her
conversation with hawk it was quite a
long message and he just sits there and
listens although he does sort of give
some indications that he understands
that he's taken it all in at the very
least so she says electricity is humming
you hear it in the mountains and rivers
you see it dance among the seas and
stars and glowing around the moon but in
these days the glow is dying what will
be in the darkness that remains the
Truman brothers are both true men they
are your brothers and the others the
good ones who have been with you now the
circle is almost complete watch and
listen to the dream of time and space it
all comes out now flowing like a river
that which is and is not hawk laura is
the one and then after that we head to
the Roadhouse which is one of my
favorite performances there because of
the timing I thought maybe there might
be something else but it does go to
credits but yeah it was it was cool it
held my attention I don't know what the
biggest moment of them all was I think
that the log lady is definitely the most
intriguing thing and there were several
funny things that happen so let me know
what you guys think in the comments
please like this video if you enjoyed it
the recap and review will be following
shortly behind I have some Game of
Thrones to do now - but don't worry I'm
not going to give up on Twin Peaks in
any way I'm really fascinated
and can't wait for each next episode
when it comes out
give me a follow over on social media
the links are in the description and
check back regularly because new stuff
will be coming out soon thanks for
watching I'll talk to you again